like every other poster boy for the new
atheism Sam Harris is all about
intellectual honesty if you don't
believe me just ask him there's uh one
algorithm I'm running more than most uh
which
is you know what I would call
intellectual honesty see I told you Sam
Harris is the Moses of the new atheists
he led his generation of budding
narcissists from the Captivity of
religion through the Red Sea of
superstition across the desert of Blind
Faith and into the Promised Land of
Science reason and logic of course there
may be some Skeptics out there some of
you Skeptics may be thinking to
yourselves but David literally the
moment people started listening to the
new atheists and turning away from
Christianity the entire world suddenly
went completely insane so maybe just
maybe these guys have absolutely no clue
what they're doing and therefore
shouldn't be trusted with the future of
humanity but that's heresy my friends
true we have zero empirical evidence
that Sam Harris and his perpetually
enraged Apostles actually know how to
improve the world in any relevant way
but that's why we need to have faith The
Atheist Utopia is on its way just
believe no matter how many times reality
smacks you in the
mouth now apart from that heartless
monster we call reality what's
preventing us from getting the Glorious
atheist Utopia we've all been longing
for like the Titanic longed for that
Iceberg the main obstacle standing in
the way of the new dawn of Science and
rationality is that some people have the
nerve to disagree with Sam Harris if we
all simply agreed with Sam Harris we'd
get an atheist Utopia
so why doesn't everyone just agree with
him well people have different
personalities different levels of
intelligence different information and
so on but the most important factor here
is that people have different
methodologies so if we want to fix the
world's problems we all need to adopt
the methodology of Sam Harris but what
is Sam's methodology exactly it took me
a while to figure out Main because
people don't always understand what
their methodologies are and so you have
to wait for them to reveal the way they
think and they usually do this by
accident Sam recently let his
methodological cat out of the bag
totally by accident and as far as I can
tell I'm the only one who caught it and
I have no idea how I'm the only one who
caught it because it seemed glaringly
obvious to me now I could just tell you
what Sam's methodology is but I'm not
going to because I'm legitimately
disturbed by the fact that I'm the only
one who noticed this I've therefore
decided to put what I watched two old
clips and then a recent clip right in
front of your face until you see it for
yourself so that you all know how to do
this on your own next time let's start
with two old clips we have to go way
back for this the first time I ever saw
Sam Harris was on an episode of the
cbear rapport Sam was promoting his book
The End of faith and he brought up the
Virgin birth if there were good reasons
to believe that Jesus was born of a
virgin or that Muhammad went to heaven
on a winged horse that would be part of
our rational worldview and it's only
when people lose their purchase on
evidence and argument when they have bad
reasons that they talk about faith Sam
then blurted out what Islam teaches
about the Virgin birth and I I've got
historical evidence the Bible tells me
Jesus was born of virgin yeah but I mean
there's your witness right there the
Bible unfortunately the Quran says that
anyone who thinks that is going to spend
eternity in hell and I thought to myself
this guy doesn't know that Muslims
believe in the Virgin birth he thinks
believing in the Virgin birth as a
one-way ticket to an eternity in Hell
according to Islam I pointed this out in
a video several years ago and Sam
responded he said that he simply
misspoke and I have no problem with that
response I miss speak all the time like
when I say that the new atheists have
powerful and persuasive arguments oh did
I say powerful and persuasive I meant
half-baked and moronic I
misspoke but it is easy to make a
mistake when you're speaking off the
cuff on a talk show so there's no reason
to hold that against
Sam imagine my surprise however when I
saw Sam's prepared remarks about Jesus
at
City you can take Jesus in half his
moods and get some really beautiful
ethical precepts like the Golden Rule
but Jesus also said things like in Luke
19 anyone who doesn't want me to to
Reign Over him bring him before me and
slay him before me so Jesus in Luke 19
orders Peter and James and John to bring
his enemies before him and to slaughter
them that's weird I don't recall the
Apostles doing anything like that maybe
I should look that one up Luke 19: 27
but those enemies of mine who did not
want me to be king over them bring them
here and kill them in front of me wow
Sam Harris is Right Jesus did say that
but wait a minute there's an extra
quotation mark here it's going on let me
back up a bit oh it's a parable it's a
story Jesus is is telling Jesus tells a
story about a king and the king in the
story orders his subjects in his kingdom
to execute people this Parable is
actually based on a true story archelus
was the son of Herod the Great after
Herod died archelus went to Rome to be
granted part of his father's Kingdom by
Caesar but his subjects rebelled against
him after receiving his kingdom he
returned and had his enemies executed
but according to Sam Harris Luke 19:27
is Jesus commanding his disciples to
slaughter his
enemies now how many people in that
audience were familiar with that Parable
in Luke
19 maybe one or two even people who had
read it before probably didn't even know
what Sam was
quoting how many people in that audience
do you think bothered to look up Luke
19:27 after Sam quoted it maybe one or
two if any and the one or two who looked
it up unless they were reading the
passage carefully would have just
skimmed the text and saw the words and
said oh my goodness that is Jesus
talking it's red letter Jesus ordered
Christians to slaughter his
enemies so the entire audience along
with countless other people who watched
the video later walked away thinking
that Luke 19 is a command to Christians
to slaughter people in the name of Jesus
and from presentations like this where
people think they're receiving accurate
information from experts in religious
studies we get the standard new atheist
position that when Christians say hey
Jesus commanded us to love our neighbors
and to love our enemies we're just
picking and choosing because he also
commanded us to slaughter
non-christians we're just going with the
teachings we prefer at the
moment now here's the interesting part
you can line up a 100 Sam Harris fans
and show them what Sam Harris says about
Jesus in Luke 19 and you can then read
Luke 19 with them and show them that
it's a king in a story who orders his
followers to execute his enemies and you
can then ask these fans if it bothers
them even slightly that Sam completely
misrepresented the passage and misled
thousands if not millions of
people 100 out of 100 Sam Harris fans
won't be bothered even slightly by the
fact that he completely misrepresented
the passage Christianity is so evil it's
so bad for the world that there's no
obligation to be honest about it you
should find this fascinating because
these are the people who brag about
their intellectual honesty when it comes
to Jesus intellectual honesty goes out
the window but you can go to these exact
same Sam Harris fans and tell them what
Sam says about gay sex
gay sex is an
Abomination what did Sam just say gay
sex is an
Abomination oh my goodness but what if
someone disagrees with Sam what does Sam
want his followers to do to people who
disagree with him anyone who doesn't
want me to to Reign Over him bring him
before me and slay him before me kind of
easy to completely misrepresent someone
like this isn't it but if you were to go
around shouting look at what Sam Harris
says about gay sex and he even says that
anyone who doesn't agree with him has to
be executed suddenly Sam's fans would
think that it's really important to
clarify context and they would say that
misrepresenting someone is wrong so if
you're misrepresenting what Jesus says
it's fine if you're misrepresenting what
Sam Harris says it's
immoral hold that thought I haven't
watched watched many Sam Harris Clips
over the years I'm guessing I've only
seen half a dozen or so clips of Sam
this is just me but once I realize that
you're talking about Christianity and
Islam and that either you don't know
what you're talking about or you do know
what you're talking about and you're
deliberately deceiving people I'm just
not that interested in what you have to
say although Sam's discussion with Ben
Affleck was epic but think about this
I haven't watched much from Sam Harris
but in the little bit that I've seen
even though I'm impressed by his courage
in the face of opposition I'm certainly
not impressed by his knowledge of
religions because in the few Clips I've
watched he doesn't seem to know what
he's talking about and yet he's propped
up as an expert by his fans what's going
on here well we're about to find out
because Sam recently did an interview
with trigonometry tons of people
criticized what Sam said in that
interview because he defended
conspiracies to control elections in
certain circumstances people flipped out
about that and yet everyone somehow
missed a much bigger issue but let's
look at the part people got mad about
Sam is discussing the social media
coverup of the hunter Biden laptop story
right before the 2020 election and he
says that there was a left-wing
conspiracy to cover up the story
and that the conspiracy was warranted
that's a just a conspir that's a
leftwing conspiracy to deny the
presidency to Donald Trump absolutely it
was absolutely right but I think it was
warranted Sam was heavily criticized for
this because it sounds like he's
suggesting that it's okay to rig
elections but in context weird how
context keeps coming up he's claiming
that when a society is facing an
existential threat a threat to the
existence of the society or to the
existence of an essential feature of the
society certain rules about fair play
just aren't that important and I think
that most people would agree with him to
an extent suppose you're a German
journalist in the 1930s and you see this
guy with a little mustache rising to
power suppose you're somehow the only
person who knows that if this guy Rises
to power he's going to get millions and
millions of people killed and you know
that you can keep him out of power by
covering up a story story telling a few
lies accusing some people of Russian
disinformation and so on you can save
millions of lives with a little
conspiracy behind the scenes I think
most people here would say you're going
to save millions of lives with a little
conspiracy yeah I can see that but what
does this have to do with Sam claiming
that a conspiracy to cover up a story
that could influence a US election is
warranted well Sam is convinced that
Donald Trump is an existential threat to
our
democracy we have a massive problem we
have an existential threat right
politically speaking I consider Trump an
existential threat to our democracy and
Sam clarifies that this isn't about left
versus right Democrat versus Republican
where this is not the same thing as not
liking George Bush you know or not
liking John McCain or not liking Mitt
Romney for their politics Donald Trump
is a special kind of dangerous a kind of
dangerous that transcends political
affiliations here's a guy
who is capable of anything right he's
not he's not ideological but he's again
he's he's a black hole of selfishness
right he's he's he's just and so there's
no telling what he's going to
do and we cannot afford to have four
more years with this guy and this puts
people who have power over the flow of
information in a difficult spot so what
what should well-intentioned people do
who have a lot of power in these various
ways you know you're running the New
York Times you're running CNN you're
running
Twitter what should they conspire to do
what should people who control what
other people see and hear conspire to do
it was appropriate for Twitter and the
heads of big Tech and journal and the
heads of journalistic organizations to
feel that they were in the presence of
something like a a once in a-lifetime
moral emergency right it's a Once in a
Lifetime moral emergency there's an
existential threat to our democracy is
this a time to be concerned about
journalistic integrity we're going to
open up this laptop from hell and the
News cycle for who knows how long is
going to be just
just conceivably just a nuclear bomb of
an octob October surprise and we're
going to get four more years of trump if
we actually give this a fair hearing
four more years of an existential threat
to our democracy if we give this a fair
hearing so should you give it a fair
hearing of course not conspiracy time
but what about the laptop what if it's
filled with horrible horrible stuff
listen I don't care what's in Hunter
Biden's I mean hunter Biden at that
point Hunter Biden literally could have
had had the corpses of children in his
basement I would not have cared Hunter
Biden was not on the ballot so news
about corpses of children in his
basement would have been a mere
distraction a distraction that could
have led to four more years of an
existential threat to our democracy what
then should journalists and texos do if
they find out that Hunter Biden is a
serial
killer they should suppress and
discredit the story until the election
is over again Hunter's not on the ballot
and literally anyone else would be less
dangerous than Trump and you know
Hillary Clinton for all of her flaws was
not worse than Trump Joe Biden for Joe
Biden we could have known Joe Biden was
going to just be Kos in office not worse
than Trump right so conspiracies are
Justified and anyone who joins the fight
for our democracy is a hero even if
she's a republican right and I think Liz
Cheney is a total hero right so so and I
don't agree with her politics at all
right like Liz Cheney is a religious
Maniac by my lights right and in in that
sense kind of a terrifying political
figure Liz Cheney was a republican
congresswoman who blasted Trump and
voted for his impeachment Sam calls her
a religious maniac so she's not the sort
of person Sam would normally support
kind of a terrifying political figure
like like like that like the the old me
who you know was just worried about the
Christian theocracy in the United States
um would have
just revolted at everything she would
attempt to implement as a politician the
old Sam Harris would have been horrified
at the thought of this religious Maniac
making policies but the new Sam Harris
is focused on Trump and she's against
Trump
so at this moment she's you know she has
no bigger fan than me now did you catch
it Sam just solved a pretty big mystery
for us I've been wondering for years how
people who constantly Pat themselves on
the back for their intellectual honesty
people who praise themselves for being
the champions of science and reason
reason and logic can suddenly become so
incredibly sloppy and even deceptive
when they talk about
Christianity Sam just solved the mystery
did you catch
it how did everyone miss this it was the
first thing that stood out to
me since you missed it let's recap I
want you to catch this without me
telling
you if something is an existential
threat to our democracy do you need to
be fair and honest when you fight
against this existential threat
no do you need to give it a fair hearing
no our conspiracies and manipulation and
deception and abuses of power warranted
when dealing with an existential threat
absolutely that's how Sam defended
conspiracies to keep Trump out of office
but then Sam blured out that while Trump
is the current existential threat a
younger Sam Harris viewed something else
as an existential threat the old me who
you know was just worried about the
Christian theocracy in the United States
did you catch it this time Sam views
Trump as an existential threat to our
democracy so conspiracies and deception
are warranted as a means of keeping
Trump from destroying our democracy but
a younger Sam Harris viewed Christianity
as an existential threat to our
democracy Christians were going to
establish a theocracy in the US unless
they were stopped by the new atheists
and their
allies so Christians were going to
destroy our democracy and replace it
with a theocracy unless they were
stopped according to Sam's rules if
you're facing an existential threat to
democracy do you need to be fair do you
need to be honest do you need to
represent Jesus accurately when you talk
about him do you need to represent the
Bible accurately when you talk about it
do you need to represent Christian
arguments accurately when you respond to
them of course not you're in a battle
for the very survival of our democracy
and so if you're in a position to shape
people's views of Jesus the Bible
Christianity
manipulation deception and even
conspiracies would all be
warranted that's Sam's methodology and
if you look closely you'll see that the
methodologies of the leaders are always
imprinted on their followers even if
their followers don't understand the
methodologies and even if the clueless
gullible followers really think their
Nature's gift to
rationality and that my friends is why
the new atheists who again portray
themselves as the champions of science
and reason and logic are absolutely
Relentless in spouting complete utter
total nonsense whenever they talk about
Jesus but if you think Sam Harris's
methodology is bad check out my video
about Richard
[Music]
Dawkins